So Martin then does is express these steps using a UML collaboration diagram.
We called that a collaboration diagram.
Was like an object diagram.
But the lines between the objects indicated our operations.
And the lines were numbered indicating the order of the operations.
So in this case, we had the steps of user interface getting,
getting the request from the user with the brew button, and
then asking the hot water source for whether it's ready.
And then asking if the containment vessel whether it's ready,
and then starting the hot water source heating up the water.
So there's three steps labeled one, two, and three here.
And we can see that there's, there ought to
be at least three classes supported to deal with those three possibilities.
>> Is it possible here for this diagram to be more descriptive?
In the sense that, it seems like when you ask the ho, hot water source.
Is it ready or not?
If it says it is ready,
then you might make the next check to see if the containment vessel's ready.
But if it says no, it seems like a whole another steps set of
steps may have to be taken to indicate to the user hey.
The water source, hot and ready to go.
>> Okay so remember that a use case, or a representation of a use case in
a collaboration diagram or a sequence diagram is not contingent.
Okay, it's, it's one step by step walk through the system.
And what we're going to have to do is to deal with contingencies which
are obviously an important part of this whole process.
We're going to have to have multiple diagrams.
And one of the things that Martin does is suggest that we can
add together those diagrams.
So, I think that maybe is where you're going.
We want to have them, them all there.
But, wha, what we'll do them a step at a time, so to speak.
>> So we would have, I guess a use-case symbol user-presses brew button and
a water vessel is not ready.
Like, that would be a separate use case and
we can model and tie that in later with this situation,
which seems like we're pressing brew and everything's ready to go.
>> That's where we're going.